I'm still ready today we're gonna play
some really really hard games don't be
turned on damn it
first game you were suggested was two
cars it can't be that hard
all right it can't be oh let's give this
car a spin take the circles [ __ ] this
happen
get all the circles they said it will be
[ __ ] fun Oh God lack of really
[ __ ] good oh damn sixteen okay let's
see if we can get it to a million nah
man [ __ ] I don't think we're gonna get
to a million damn this game is really
[ __ ] hot I can do two things in one
it's like having two flappy birds and
you have to fly it with both I'm having
the time you son of I can't think for
two peep I can't I can barely think for
myself how am I gonna think for two
people Oh what was I supposed to do that
click well you haven't played have you
played this game no yes you have well
you're the higher high score like that's
impossible
I just snotted all over my microphone
you're welcome microphone thanks prayers
oh my god oh my god 30 this game this
dis game this game this game this game
game focus your mind
Oh Oh what no I bet you don't have that
high score [ __ ] see you come on
this game is like talking to your
girlfriend when shes up saying one wrong
move and you're dead
alright I got it I [ __ ] got it look at
this [ __ ] look at the [ __ ] why aren't
you looking at my shape
ah pop whoa oh holy [ __ ] my ass out that
was I'm never ever ever gonna be that
that was best best game someone
suggested be shibashi but Spanky Piggy
came up so we're gonna play that instead
story there's a story there's a story
okay I want it oh don't present yourself
like I Pig have some goddamn [ __ ]
integrity mmm I ding ding dong I'm
spanking pig's best best game best game
what's the goddamn [ __ ] story the
story is how miserable my life is shut
don't judge me
you're a pig [ __ ] mmm face it someone
suggested faces let's try it out what
the [ __ ] what what is white what is that
welcome to face ah thanks for the
welcoming oh god I bet I don't think I'm
supposed to touch the black ones this
game is a little racist but that's how
[ __ ] sorry a game for calling you're
racist I didn't think you'd actually
hear me I jump on the white ones to
progress this is also like real life oh
my god
damn it I need to stop your social
commentary can you feel the sunshine
does it matter it [ __ ] me game wants
me to install heroes charge this game is
high so easy my god easiest game ez game
ez game look at that
don't you didn't look did you good you
look so good today please like this
video just for no reason
easy watch this first try e next rage
game is feed a burger that looks pretty
cute I don't see a game like this being
hard or anything alright I played enough
Cooking Mama to know that cooking games
are difficult alright
what ah you want to play rough I'll play
rough baby why I think what dish this
game is impossible bread butter [ __ ]
fudge [ __ ] but [ __ ] I did I say I didn't
mom don't listen to my videos mom la
Allen what are you doing
how did I get up me video there's
another what are you kidding me I just
randomly found no I have to try it I'll
have to try it I can't I can't I can't
believe this [ __ ] three [ __ ] cars its
who would play this
alright god I got it I can't
alright [ __ ] this game [ __ ] everyone who
made [ __ ] everyone who don't made it
[ __ ] everyone I hope you enjoyed
watching this video if you did leave a
like and subscribe convert today and
let's always keep on reaching Danny's
brother
[Music]